ah ecco no non lo voglia che palle
guarda tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video di super meat boy
oggi mi servirò un po di merd ultima
volta è stata una infatti l'arma
infattibile vediamo the times bill se
già più fatti che succede ma è una città
vera io pensavo fosse distrutta perfetto
questo zitto prossimo la cosa è stato ma
è il cattivo di te townsville no the
famous wars venienti la battaglia del
feto comincia il sign forno e bejing
attacchiamo aggressivamente va bene
the times bill gross sette livelli si
può e non so pensava per la velocità è
mica quali stoffa a con questi vai
avanti solo se tv il pugno va bene ma
questo come concetto è una figata raga
questo come concetto se mi permettete
una figata
ok ok ok mi che ho imparato subito il
fenomeno nom in chiave lo fanno tutto
senza morire sarebbe stato un sogno che
si è fatta ma do stavo passando in mezzo
a cui 26 trovare se ci riusciva guarda a
me la prendo tranquillo e perché dovrei
farcela tranquillamente
noto anche rischio è bellissimo bravo
bravo
mi sono piaciuto mi sono piaciuto per il
primo livello non è male ai ragazzi
perché quali sarà essere seria la coda
non oso pensare a quanti incazzato il
sole non oso pensare il boss finale di
sta roba non le chiavi nicchia mi
mancavano ragazzi le chiavi anche super
meat boy normale terra ok quindi adesso
in avanti devo prendere anche delle
chiavi per andare alla juve ci mancava
sta roba
peccato avevo fatto provate ma fa niente
dove vado l'ho presa bene o non capisco
niente ma dai avevo fatto tutto avevo
fatto tutto in una maniera pazzesca
ho fatto tutto giusto ma dai ma dai non
farò mai più
ho fatto rete provate infinite non ce la
farò mai più ragazzi ma mai più il
proprio
madre ce l'ho fatto perché ok ok ok
tutto lui ho sbagliato all'ultima perché
sono una talpa fosso del cervello e
fratello devi muoverti e vabbè quanto
cacchio ci mettevo l'affare grazie roma
coi tuoi tempi e per carità dei tempi 10
morti ma questa volta se episodio non
sta andando male perché contiamo che
siamo all'inizio e che cosa è successo
passa in mezzo ai gruppi di ieri e
quindi è una dinamica passare in mezzo
ai tubini spiegamento si è una dinamica
quindi serve attenzione e mamma mia
perfetto siamo già a metà livello 4 arco
demonio l'ho detto ok ok piero non è
veduevidue due chiavi in mano bene
bastava una 22 chiavi di due chiavi a
una per andare lì e poi torna indietro
ok adesso ad andare a sinistra nicchia
stavo morendo perché qualcosa ma punta
verso il basso che maledetti
le puntate sono morto si muove ora
ragazzi c'è stade frutta st episodio
sono morto pochissime volte fino a molo
detto mario un miliardo di volte santoli
schiatto ok perfetto
ce l'ho fatta bravissimo ora che non
solo portare anche una volta si aumenta
livello solo questo voglio dirvi solo
questo riunirli neanche una volta sono
morto ecco metà livello senza morire è
un record non è vero perfetto
no no no ma donna stava morendo in modo
orribile
c'è un bug c'è un bug cos'è sta roba qua
sicuro che non debba andare così ma
forse devo ho capito capitolo no sono
morto una volta che idiota
devo fare così pirla non avevo capito
subito
peccato no non è vero mi dissocio
se non fossi morto quella volta sarei
facendo tutto rifila fidatevi
fidatevi se non fossi morto quella
singola volta
porca vacca peccato ma forse lo puntare
verso il basso vediamo
no è bellissimo mamma mia che ansia
mamma mia che ansia sul finale non basta
e taurino 13 morti laga normale perché
inizio avevo fatto uno sbaglio
siamo al quinto siamo molto meglio tener
premuto immaginato madonna il casinò
devo tenere premuto sul rampino è
diventato già scò qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegare perché io ho bisogno di capire
se qualcuno ha voglia di spiegare io
sono qua pronto a capire per cortesia
ragazzi nei commenti qualcuno mi spieghi
porco del demonio incastrato nelle città
del tetano porta la butta sporca
spiegatemi che cosa devo fare ok a posto
era giusto era giusto e cielo anche
pasta questo commento ecco no non lo 0 0
va bene tutto ma no ma devo fare
scendere qualcosa che spacchi tutto devo
fare a è quello
12 mannaggia che finirà incredibile ok
ce l'ho fatta perché 68 morti e record e
record mondiale
per adesso il mio record continua
mancano manca a2a thriving siamo messi
sempre uguale 550 mila di calcio
auspichiamo alto livello
mamma mia che bordello tutto ok tutto
tutto che col esce tutto le collection
no ce l'avevo fatta pensa quelli che se
li fanno ragazzi in una vita sola senza
mai morire perché ci sono ovviamente
anzi ho visto pista non mi stupirei se
ci fossero già nonostante sia passato di
niente da quando incito suo gioco non mi
stupirei per nulla
ma come fare allora spiegamelo ce l'ho
fatta incredibile non morire perché non
saprei di farlo meraviglioso vedere se
si riesce a fare senza chiave radio ce
l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta senza chiave
incredibile sicura la presenza
bellissimo per una volta un'altra vita
che funzioni che oggi
accendiamo un cero next level arriva al
boss ragazzi la black guardian su pc c'è
sempre altro archivio c'è mio figlio che
si prepara ora ragazzo lei veniva noi
due
strumenti che nel prezzo di queste guide
le salvare i genitori si scommettono lo
volete raga il contrario
[Musica]
questa la vedo complicata ragazzo forse
anche più di quello del boss
dell'episodio scorso proviamoci ragazzo
è allora già mi fa paura
sono morto no no non so non capisco io
devo fare ragazzi voglio arrivare alla
fase due
ancora non l'ho superato la 1 non lo so
ma non posso pensare neanche come
cacchio può essere la fase dura non ho
superato anche la prima a dire che
questo non è neanche randomico gli altri
boss sono randomico si difende come
chiuderà questo ma non è nemmeno ne andò
miccoli possa avere un pattern
predefinito che non riesco comunque a
fare che pensate
metti metti metti mammamia meno male ce
l'ho fatta la prima fase è fatta sì c'è
ma wiwa subito subito lo finisco certo
e quando mai dovrebbe essere un problema
tutto ciò ma quando l'ho mai toccata
quota fino a certo la mia mano un attimo
che arrivò e amanti sta roba arrivo a
mangiare certo sicuro ma adesso non
finisco un attimo ragazzi un attivissimo
alpini vero è finito secondo lei mi sono
fatto 12 fa
2 va giù giù giù ok e manca tutto
l'altro 12 e non si può fare sì
ok
[Musica]
ci sono tre usa quanti ce n'erano tre io
no ma voi siete veramente usciti di
cervello ok mentre come li basso scusa
ma com'è che volevo farli 3
[Musica]